[Música]
todos nacemos siendo emprendedores se
dieron cuenta es como algo que está en
nuestro adn los animales cazan las
personas emprendemos los niños son
emprendedores se les rompe un juguete no
hay problema enseguida sirve para otra
cosa si no hay para autos eléctricos
bueno agarramos un autito de plástico le
ponemos una cucharita de metal y anda
más rápido
si se nos fue la mano con la tijerita al
cortarle el pelo a la barbie la
convertimos en otro personaje y ahora es
la barbe maléfica la desgraciada que se
roba todos los que en de todas las
barbies
los niños son emprendedores son
valientes son corajudos son atrevidos
hasta que llegan a la escuela
en la escuela esos sueños esa capacidad
de emprender el deseo de hacer toda la
iniciativa se queda en el cajón de los
juguetes abandonados con el autito de
carrera y la barba y tejiendo telarañas
la escuela es como un monstruo donde la
prueba las faltas las amonestaciones el
acto peina te vestiste todos peinaditos
todos realitos todos iguales si es con
uniforme si es con delantal a que
madrugar y poco a poco nos vamos
olvidando de esa capacidad de emprender
que teníamos y esa capacidad de soñar se
va esfumando
ojo no digo que está mal la escuela es
bárbara la escuela es maravillosa pero
si vamos a la escuela porque no sabemos
por qué es tan grave no aprobar
la realidad es que las escuelas de
alguna manera nos llevan a otro estado
de ánimo en el que es lo que importa es
aprobar y no aprender aparece el
monstruo del boletín que va a decir tu
papá y así poco a poco ese emprendedor
ese pibe emprendedor esa piba
emprendedora se preocupa solamente por
las notas
pero ojo hay una buena noticia en el
mundo
está teniendo lugar un movimiento que la
gente del marketing y de la publicidad
lo llama el timbre en eur ismo en
español a mí me gusta llamarlo pibe
emprendedor puede ser emprendes entes
que son unos pibes que no renuncian a
sus sueños que no renuncian a su deseo
de hacer de este mundo algo mejor
jacques andraca es un pibe que a los 15
años descubrió un método para la
detección temprana del cáncer de
páncreas que arrojó un 90% efectividad y
cuesta sólo 3 centavos de dólar
málaga seguramente escucharon hablar de
málaga una chiquita que fue el talibán
intentó matarla y ella no sólo
sobrevivió sino que renació con más
fuerza y lucha para que las niñas
paquistaníes puedan tener acceso a la
educación a los libros en 2014 fue
premio nobel de la paz y si hablo de
premio nobel de la paz
greta zoom ver en suecia no la que ha
movido y movilizado a todos los
estudiantes en esto que se llama friday
for future se si escucharon hablar que
es un movimiento que pretende a través
de huelgas pacifistas hacer que los
adultos las autoridades los gobiernos
tomen conciencia de que estamos
arruinando el planeta de que el cambio
climático se va a acabar con todos
nosotros
pero la buena noticia es que esto pasa
en el mundo pero también pasa acá porque
argentina es parte del mundo estamos más
lejos está más al sur no seremos
europeos pero somos partes del mundo y
acá tenemos también un montón de pibe
emprendedores si no tú bar o tal vez se
hizo conocido porque cuando vino barack
obama lo convocó y lo mencionó sino tu
barrio era un pibe de barrio humilde al
que un maestro descubrió en la escuela y
lo llevó y pidió para que le dieran una
beca en la escuela técnica más
importante de buenos aires y hoy es el
que descubrió diseña las manos las
prótesis de manos para los chiquitos que
tuvieron un accidente o nacieron con una
malformación eso era maravilloso pero no
es sólo eso lo que hizo lo que hizo fue
liberar esos planos para que cualquiera
pueda bajarse el archivo e imprimir una
mano para un chiquito por apenas unos
pesos también está ade en días no será
que es un pibe que hace bio impresión
que trabaja con los órganos de los
animales para imprimir
órganos que puedan ayudarnos a hacer
trasplantes para los seres humanos y los
hermanos díaz que crearon la aplicación
está la ots project que sirve para que
las personas con autismo se puedan
comunicar con lenguajes visuales y los
hermanos coopi a una de ellas tuve la
oportunidad de tenerla como alumna que
diseñaron un software para que su madre
que tenía síndrome de ella' pudiera
comunicarse con todos ellos a través de
la mirada
simplemente tipeando con los ojos todo
eso es en córdoba estos pibes también
están los de confusión están los de
dónde le esto está pasando acá entonces
la escuela puede ser un monstruo pero
nosotros podemos accionar yo lo que les
pido a ustedes es que jaque en esta
tendencia a renunciar a nuestros sueños
y estar dentro del sistema a
obsesionarnos por aprobar no pasa nada
con la nota lo que importa tiene que ser
aprender y más que nada les diría más
que aprender es emprender o sea aprender
para
ok bárbaro qué bien que suena pero como
hacemos bueno como yo no puedo escapar
un poquito mi vocación de maestra
ciruela y estoy todo el tiempo educando
vengo con cinco consejos a ver si les
vienen bien el primer consejo que tengo
para darles es busquen se un padrino
pueden ser los pibes de club este de
pueden ser algún maestro de la escuela
saben una cosa jack andraca el pibe que
antes le mencionaba que es de eeuu de un
proyecto que se llama maryland contó con
la complicidad de su profe de química
que le abría a la noche el laboratorio
para que practicara
tengan un socio busquen a alguien que
les dé esa contención que les dé
respuestas que les dé herramientas
segundo sueñen nos acostumbramos a no
soñar hay que madrugar hay que valerse
hay que lavarse los dientes de que
tuviera que probar a probar a probar a
probar sueñen porque los adultos cuando
emprenden emprenden para no madrugar
emprenden para no fumar se al jefe pero
los pibes cuando emprenden emprenden
para cumplir un sueño es fundamental
tener ese sueño no lo renuncien y
busquen lo busquen su propósito busquen
eso que los mueve tercero hagan que no
sirve nada tener un sueño si no vamos a
hacer no saben a greta zoom ver la
chiquita que ahora va a ser premio nobel
del ave está nominada ojalá cuando
siempre el premio nobel de paz fueron
premios para personas de más de 60 a 70
pirulos no todo esto es lo que están
haciendo ustedes greta estaba
diagnosticada con autismo
pero hizo ella creyó en su sueño en su
idea y la hizo como la hizo haciendo
cuarto comuniquen una idea que queda
adentro del cajón y que nadie la conoce
es una idea que muere estamos en la era
del copyleft que es lo opuesto al
copyright el copyright que nos decía
hazlo registras te registraste tu idea
porque le van a robar el copyleft es
suelto suelto hago cuento comunico
difundo que lo sepan todos estoy en este
plan
tengo esta idea estoy pensando qué hacer
con esta basura estoy queriendo hacer
esto con las personas con dificultades
auditivas cuenten comuniquen difundan
son maestros de redes de hecho ustedes
han sido los que seguramente escucharon
esa frase por ahí que dice el trabajo
que vas a hacer cuando termine el
colegio todavía no existen
no están inventando ustedes los
influencias las inventaron ustedes los
youtubers los inventaron ustedes hay la
hija de una amiga mía trabaja cobrando
un fee para ayudar a la gente a pasar de
nivel en el videojuego
si ustedes inventan trabajos inventen
nuevos trabajos
y finalmente les voy a decir el último
consejo que es no trabajen solos
viste uno tiende decir esta es mi idea y
el emprendedor el emprendedurismo el
querer emprender es de mucha soledad
jacques andraca había mandado 300 mails
a 300 laboratorios para que le aprobaran
el proyecto pero si se os dan cuatro
veces previa matemática está mal no no
está mal es el tiempo que necesitas
entonces
búsquense un par un compañero una dupla
don mischer y 'batman y robin' hansel y
gretel
harry potter curación harry potter
singer mayo ni un plomo
busquen un par busquen un otro es normal
por eso el amor verdad y digo esto no
piensen no estoy diciendo que la escuela
está mal la escuela está buenísima
encontramos amigos el primer amor los
primeros besos las primeras aventuras
las primeras salidas del viaje de
egresados
entonces vayamos a la escuela pero no
soltemos esos sueños y a cambio de estos
cinco tips que les di de pedir un único
favor
la próxima vez que vayan a un cumpleaños
a una reunión familiar
un evento social y aparezca una de esas
viernes esas tías que todos tenemos
medio regordeta zipper maquilladas con
el peinado todo con spray y los agarre
el cachete liga a ver jovencito que va a
ser usted cuando sea grande díganle
mirándola a los ojos no sé qué voy a
hacer pero si sé lo que voy a hacer voy
a tratar de arreglar con mis sueños el
quilombo que todos ustedes nos dejaron
muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]